[Music]
a teen girl and her boyfriend accused of
killing her father enter
not guilty please this is a story the
i-team first broke in april
after the body of daniel hauseth was
discovered the i-team's vanessa murphy
has more on what unfolded inside a las
vegas courtroom today
sierra hal said then aaron guerrero
entered not guilty pleas
as the i-team first reported before
their arrest
they recorded a video referring to a
murder and laughing
today in court was a much different tone
[Music]
the list of charges against 16-year-old
sierra helseth and her 18-year-old
boyfriend aaron guerrero
includes murder conspiracy to commit
murder arson
robbery and fraud do you understand the
nine charges that you're facing in the
indictment
yes the teens quietly stand next to each
other as they answer the judge's
questions
not guilty but back in april metro
police say they recorded this video
before they were taken into custody
welcome back to our youtube channel
day three after murdering somebody whoa
don't put that on the camera
investigators say the teens
killed sierra's father 45 year old
daniel halseth and tried to dismember
and burn his body the halseth family has
been in the public eye before
sierra's mother elizabeth hauseth is a
former nevada state senator
and the parents contentious relationship
which resulted in their split
also made headlines do you understand
the proceedings that are happening here
today
now the case against sierra hellseth and
aaron guerrero
is moving forward it was worth it the
teen's next court date is set for
august vanessa murphy 8 news now
in our state if an individual aged 16 or
older is charged with murder
they're charged as an adult and that's
why sierra hauseth is now in the adult
system however according to jail records
it appears she is being held in the
juvenile facility